As you can see, it is winter weather, and we are
spoiled. I mean, we also had
young children. I mean, at the same time, I don't know how to
wash them. I have to
take a shower. The answer is, of course, our eyes will not be wasted. Water is wasted. I mean, there's not even the existing Nile. If we have it, we'll make it transparent, and this is
expensive, by God.  Look for a solution for us. We are humans, not
animals. I mean, there are people who are afraid of
animals. They fear animals more than
humans. We are humans. We
exist. We do not know how to sleep, we do not know how to live, and we do not know how to teach our children. We do not know how to teach them
that we are five years into the
fifth month. We still do not know how to teach
our children. The children are learning.  But if they go and get
wood, they go and get firewood, they go and make a fire, they go and
get water, this is our life, but
eating, drinking, and water, and it depends on eating and drinking, even in good
health, as you can see, they are canned food. We eat, by God, what is wrong with you? I mean, I don’t
have anything. I mean, do you advise me anything?
For example, I had a mobile phone with me, which I sold
electrical appliances that I had brought with me
from Gaza. Uncle, manage our affairs. How are
we? Where we are sitting, there is no entrance. I mean, we have an entrance. I see the
situation in the country, how it is. There is no money, no
work, nothing.